well this morning we're taking a look at
the 2024 Republican race for president
and a telling moment for a potential
candidate former vice president Mike
Pence he strongly criticized former
president Donald Trump on Saturday for
the January 6 assault on the capitol
Pence said quote history will hold
Donald Trump accountable for his actions
and that in his words quote endangered
my family and everyone at the Capitol
that day Robert Costa is covering the
2024 race and he is here with us Bob
welcome back from Iowa thank you uh why
do you think uh former vice president
Mike Pence is criticizing uh his former
boss or colleague depending on how you
view it right now this all comes as the
former vice presidents in a legal
standoff over whether he will testify in
that grand jury investigation in
Washington but politically he's moving
closer to a 2024 presidential bid and he
believes when you talk to his close
allies that he can draw a contrast with
Trump and offer himself to the Trump
Coalition as someone who has an
ideological tie to them but on conduct
and character can offer an alternative
so is he testing the waters oh he is
moving closer certainly testing the
waters let's talk about Michael Cohen
the former personal attorney for uh the
former president uh he's before a grand
jury looking into alleged hush money
payments to adults film star Stormy
Daniels what's what's the significance
of this and potentially what can happen
the big picture here is it's sometimes
complicated to follow all the ongoing
investigations of former president Trump
you have the grand jury in Washington
you got the investigation in Georgia and
you also have this Manhattan district
attorney looking into the payments May
made by Michael Cohen to an adult film
star in 2016. and based on our reporting
it looks like this Manhattan D.A
investigation could be the one could
that indicts Trump in the coming weeks
Michael Cohen will come in today and he
will testify before the grand jury legal
experts say this is a sign that that
investigation is moving closer than to
indicting something it's much to do
about nothing when you hear an
investigation like this you think
there's a chance that he would actually
be charged and the it'd be very
interesting to see what exactly he's
charged for it would be for some kind of
crime potentially about how that expense
payment was allocated and how when a
hush money payment is made how it's
listed on the company balance sheet all
right I want to talk about Pence again
and also Ron DeSantis so so Pence
criticized uh former president Trump but
he's also funnier than I've seen him and
I I covered him back and showed his
personality radio show host you never
forget that you do forget that uh so you
know he had a joke about uh he's a man
of Faith his preferred pronouns are thou
and thine which apparently was very good
in the room working on multiple levels
he also had a line about Ron DeSantis
who could be a competitor for the
nomination the Republican side he said
uh you know he's got those Everyman
populous qualities just so relatable
degrees from Harvard and Yale
he's already on Pence isn't even running
but he certainly is willing to take that
stance on DeSantis was in Iowa where you
were he's got a book that he's promoting
there what are you hearing about his
chances with the Republican base there
what was striking sitting down with
Iowans over the last few days sitting
down with the governor the Republican
Kim Reynolds is how everybody on the
Republican side in the Hawkeye State
they tell CBS This is an open race yes
they like Trump yes they've supported
him before but they're listening to
Pence they've shot they're showing up
for DeSantis I saw hundreds come out for
him they're listening to Nikki Haley I
saw her on a snowy night a few people
came out a few dozen people to listen to
her they're giving everybody a listen
it's early the challenge in Iowa is it's
not just a TV advertisement you have to
shake the hand look people in the eye
it's still that kind of state that's
that Midwest feel right yeah Bob we
appreciate it thank you